contes en commun tous ces articles
beaucoup de gens les commandes mais ne
les reçoivent jamais c'est ce qu'on
appelle larnack liées à la non livraison
et ça se passe beaucoup beaucoup sur les
réseaux sociaux en 2020 les canadiens
ont déclaré avoir perdu environ 9
millions de dollars en commandant ses
articles ça s'était déclaré le centre
antifraude estime que les pertes réelles
sont 20 fois plus grande comment éviter
de se faire prendre au piège les
fraudeurs font des fautes de frappe ou
d'orthographe repérer les y at il une
adresse un numéro de téléphone
tapez le nom de l'entreprise suivi du
mot arnaque ou fraude ou le mot anglais
scam fouiller dans les résultats
et surtout méfiez vous de vous même en
fin de soirée vous êtes moins vigilants
passés le mot
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]